I call my I have called myself at times  and no ethic archaeologist what I like  to do is go and dig not pot shards and  glass beads but ideas old old ideas that  have been under the dirt a long long  time and this is what I essentially did  here with the itching and Gnosticism is  another boneyard and alchemy is another  boneyard and the Maya are another  boneyard and ancient Hawaii is another  and I love to go into these things and  draw conclusions you know it's all very  pregnant with intention toward leave the  person who comes to it with an open mind  I mean everything wants to speak  everything wants to die this but my  approach to this kind of thing is  basically young and I mean that's where  I got my interest in all of this  material see I think that what we are  always seeing this psyche that we're  always seeing a mirroring of the  intentionality of ourselves to  concretize consciousness to put a name  on it